the following is a conversation with
richard rangham a biological
anthropologist at harvard specializing
in the study of primates and the
evolution of violence sex
cooking culture and other aspects of ape
and human behavior at the individual and
societal level
he began his career over four decades
ago working with jane goodall and
studying the behavior of chimps and
since then has done a lot of seminal
work on human evolution and has proposed
several theories for the roles of fire
and violence in the evolution of us
hairless apes otherwise known as homo
sapiens
this is the lex friedman podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now here's my
conversation with richard wrangham
you've said that we are much less
violent than our close living relatives
the chimps
can you elaborate on this point
of how violent we are and how violent
our evolutionary relatives are
well i haven't said exactly that we're
less violent than chimps what i've said
is that there are two kinds of violence
one stems from proactive aggression and
the other stems from reactive aggression
proactive aggression is planned
aggression reactive aggression is
impulsive defensive it's reactive
because
it takes place in
seconds after the threat
and the thing that is really striking
about humans compared to
our close relatives
is the great reduction in the degree of
of reactive aggression so we are far
less violent than chimps
when
prompted by some relatively minor threat
within our own society and the way i
judge that
is um with not super satisfactory data
but
the
the study which is particularly striking
is
one of
people living as
hunter-gatherers in
a really
um upsetting kind of environment namely
um people in australia
living in a place where
they got a lot of alcohol abuse
there's a lot of domestic violence
it's all
a sort of
a a society that is um
you know as bad from the point of view
of violence as
an ordinary society can get
there's excellent data on the frequency
with which people actually have physical
violence and hit each other and we can
compare that to
data from
several different sites comparing we're
looking at chimpanzee and bonobo
violence and the
difference is uh between two and three
orders of magnitude
the frequency with which chimps and
bonobos hit each other chase each other
charge each other
uh physically engage
is something between 500 and 1000 times
uh higher than in humans so there's
something just amazing about us and you
know this has been recognized for for
centuries uh aristotle drew attention to
the fact that we behave in many ways
like domesticated animals because we're
so unviolent
but you know
people say well what about you know the
hideous engagements of this
20th century
the the first and second world war and
and much else besides
and
that is all proactive violence you know
all of that is
is gangs of people
uh
making deliberate decisions to go off an
attack
in circumstances which ideally uh the
attackers are going to be able to make
their
kills and then get out of there
in other words not
face confrontation that's the ordinary
way that arm is trying to work
and um
and there
it turns out that uh humans and
chimpanzees are in a very similar kind
of state that's to say if you look at
the
the rate of death from chimpanzees
conducting proactive coalitionary
violence
it's very similar in many ways to what
you see in humans
so when not down regulated with
proactive violence it's just this
reactive violence that is
strikingly reduced in humans
so chimpanzees also practice kind of
tribal warfare
indeed they do yeah
so this was discovered first in 1974 it
was observed first 974.
which was about the time that
um
the
first
major study of chimpanzees in the wild
by jane goodall
had been going for
something like five years
during
of
the chimpanzees being observed wherever
they went
until then they'd been observed
at a feeding station where jane was
luring them into
to be observed by seeing bananas which
is great
she learned a lot but she didn't learn
what was happening at the edges of their
ranges
so five years later
it became
very obvious that there was hostile
relationships between groups
and those hostile relationships
sometimes
take the form of the kind of hostile
relationships that you see in many
animals which is a bunch of
chimps in this case uh
shouting uh at a bunch of other chimps
uh on their borders
but dramatically in addition to that
there is a second kind of interaction
and that is
when
a a party of chimpanzees
makes a
deliberate venture uh to the edge of
their territory
silently
and then
search for members of neighboring groups
and what they're searching for is a lone
individual
so i've been with chimps when they've
heard a lone individual under these
circumstances
or what they think is a lone one and
they touch each other and look at each
other and then charge forward
very excited
and then
while they're charging
all of a sudden
the place where they heard a lone call
erupts with a volley of calls it was
just one calling out of a larger party
and our chimps put on the brakes and
scoot back for safety into their own
territory but if in fact they do find a
lone individual and they they can sneak
up to them
then they make a deliberate attack uh
they're hunting
they're stalking and hunting and and
then they impose terrible damage which
typically ends in a kill straight away
but it might end up with the victim
so damaged that they'll crawl away and
die a few days
or hours later
so that was a very dramatic discovery
because it really
made people
realize for the first time that conrad
lorenz had been wrong when in the 1960s
in his famous book on aggression he said
warfare is restricted to humans animals
do not deliberately kill each other well
now we know that actually there's a
bunch of animals that deliberately kill
each other and they always do so under
essentially the same circumstances which
is
when they feel safe doing it so humans
feel safe doing it when they got a
weapon
animals
feel safe when they have a coalition
a coalition that has overwhelming power
compared to the victim and so wolves
will do that and lions will do that and
hyenas will do that and chimpanzees will
do it and and humans do it too
can they pull themselves
into something that looks more like a
symmetric war as opposed to an
asymmetric one so accidentally engaging
on the lone individual and getting
themselves into trouble
are they more aggressive in avoiding
these kinds of battles no they're very
very keen to avoid those kinds of
battles but occasionally
they can make a mistake
but
so far
there have been no observations of
anything like a battle in which both
sides maintain themselves and
i think you can very confidently say
that
overwhelmingly what happens is that if
they discover that there's several
individuals on the other side then both
sides retreat
nobody wants to get hurt
what they want to do is to hurt others
yes so you mentioned jane goodall
you've worked with her
what was it like working with her what
have you learned from her
well she's a wonderfully independent
um courageous person you know who
she
famously began her studies
not as a qualified person
in terms of
education
but
qualified only by enthusiasm and
considerable experience even in her
early 20s with nature
uh
so she's courageous in the sense of
being able to you know take on our
challenges
the thing that is very impressive about
her is
her
total fidelity to the observations
uh very unwilling to extend
uh beyond the observations uh we know
waiting until they mount up and you've
really got a confident picture
and
tremendous attention to
individuals
so
you know that was an interesting problem
from her point of view because
when she got to know the chimpanzees
of of gombe this particular community of
casa kayla about 60 individuals
oh so gombe was in tanzania on
lake tanganyika she was there initially
with her mother and then alone for
two or three years of really intense
observation
and then slowly joined by other people
what um
what she discovered was that there were
obvious differences in
individual personality and the
difficulty about that was that
when she reported this to
uh
the largest scientific world initially
her advisors at cambridge
uh
they said well you know we don't know
how to handle that because uh you've got
to treat all these animals as the same
basically because
um
there is no
research tradition of thinking about
personalities well now
whatever it is 60 years later
the study of personalities is
is a very rich part of the study animal
behavior
at any rate the important point in terms
of you know what was she like is that
she stuck to her guns and she absolutely
insisted that you know we have to
show
describe in great detail the differences
in personality among these individuals
and then you can leave it to the
evolutionary biologist to think about
what it means
so what is the process of observation
like this
like observing the personality but also
observing in a way
that's not projecting your beliefs about
human nature or animal nature onto
chimps
which is probably really tempting
to project so your understanding of the
way the human world works projecting
that onto
the chimp world
yes i mean it's particularly difficult
with chimps because chimps are so
similar to humans in their behavior
that it's very
easy
to make those projections as you say
the process involves
making very clear definitions of of what
a behavior is
you know aggression
can be defined in terms of
a forceful hit a byte and so on
and uh writing down every time these
things happen
and then slowly totting up the numbers
of times that they happen uh you know
from individual a towards individuals b
c d and e
so that you build up a very concrete
picture rather than interpreting at any
point and stopping and saying well you
know they seem to be rather aggressive
so the
sort of formal system is that you build
up a pattern of the relationships based
on
a description of the different types of
interactions the aggressive and the
friendly interactions
um and all of these are defined in
concrete
and
so that from that you extract a pattern
of relationships
and the relationships uh can be defined
as
relatively friendly relatively uh
aggressive competitive uh based on the
frequency of these types of interactions
and so one can talk in terms of
uh individuals having
a relationship which uh on the scores of
friendliness is
two standard deviations outside the mean
i mean
you know it's in which direction sorry
uh in both directions
well i mean you know there will be
obviously the friendly ones would be the
ones who have exceptionally high rates
of uh spending time close to each other
of touching each other in a gentle way
of grooming each other
and by the way finding that those things
are correlated with each other
so
it's possible to define
a friendship with a capital f in a very
systematic way and and to compare that
uh between
uh individuals but also between
communities of chimpanzees
and between different species
so that you know we can say that in some
species individuals have friends and
others they don't at all
what about just because there's
different personalities and because
they're so fascinating what about sort
of falling in love or
forming friendships with chimps you know
like really
you know um connecting with them
as an observer what what role does that
play because you're tracking these
individuals that are full of life and
intelligence from for
long periods of time plus as a human
especially in those days for jane she's
alone
observing it he gets lonely as a human i
mean probably deeply lonely as a human
being observe these other intelligent
species
it's a very reasonable question and of
course jane in those early years i think
she's willing now to talk about the fact
that
uh she regrets to some extent how close
she became
um and the problem is not just from the
humans the problem is from the
chimpanzees as well because
they do things that are
extremely affectionate if you like
you know
at one point
jane
offered a a ripe fruit
to a chimpanzee called david greybeard
david greybeard um
took it and squeezed her hand
as if to say thank you and then i think
he gave it back if i remember rightly
yeah
[Laughter]
no thank you
right
um
oh it's almost like thank you and uh
returning the affection by giving the
food yeah if if they didn't you know it
was a gentle squeeze yeah i mean
chimpanzees could squeeze you very hard
as that occasionally has happened
um some chimps are aggressive to people
um and others are friendly
and the ones that are friendly tend to
be rather sympathetic characters because
they might be ones who are having
problems in their own society
you know so jomio in gombe used to uh
come and sit next to me quite often
um and
he was having a hard time making it in
that society you know which i can
describe to you in terms of the number
of aggressive interactions if you want
you know but
um just to be informed about it
so
all of this is a temptation to be very
firmly resisted
and
in the community that i've been working
with in uganda for the last 30 years we
try
extremely hard to impress on all of the
research students who come with us that
it is absolutely vital that you do not
fall into that temptation now you know
we heard a story of one person who did
reach out and touch one of our chimps
it's a very very bad idea
not because the chimp is going to
do anything violent at the time
but because
if they learn
that humans are as weak uh physically as
we are compared to them then they can
take advantage of it
us and that's what happened in gambi so
after jane had
done the um you know very obvious thing
when you're first engaged in this
game
of uh allowing the infants to approach
her and then tickling them and playing
with them
some of those infants
had the personality
of wanting to take advantage of that
knowledge later
and so you know you had an individual
frodo who was
um violent on a regular basis towards
humans when he was an adult and he was
quite dangerous i mean he could easily
have killed someone in fact he did kill
on one person he killed a baby
that he he took from a mother a human
baby that he took off her hip when he
met her on the path
so it's a reminder that we're dealing
with
a species
that are rather human-like in the range
of emotions they have in the capacities
they have and even uh in the strength
they have they are uh
you know
in many ways stronger than humans so
it's uh
you you've got to be careful
in the full range of friendliness and
violence the capacity for these
very human things
yes i mean it's it's very obvious with
with violence as we talked about you
know that
they will kill they will kill not just
strangers
um
they can
kill
other adults within their own group uh
they can kill babies that are strangers
they can kill babies in their own group
so you know they're
this is a long-lived individual
obviously these killings can't have very
often because otherwise they'd all be
dead
um
and uh we're now finding that they can
live to 50 or 60 years in the wild at
relatively low population density
because they're big animals eating a
rather specialized kind of food the ripe
fruits
um
so it doesn't happen all the time with
friendliness
they are very strong to support each
other they very much depend on their um
their close friendships
which they express through
physical contact
and particularly through through
grooming
so grooming
occurs when one individual approaches
another i might present
for grooming a very common way of
starting
turning their back or presenting an arm
or something like that and the other
just riffles their fingers through the
hair
and that's partly just soothing
and it's partly uh looking for parasites
but mostly it's just soothing yes and
and the point about this is it can go on
for uh
half an hour it can go on for sometimes
even an hour
so this is amazing you know a major
expression of interest in somebody else
when did your interest
in this one particular aspects of jim
come to be which is violence
when did the study of violence and
chimps
uh become something you're deeply
interested in
well
um for my phd in the early 1970s
i was in gombe with jane goodall and was
studying feeding behavior
but during that time we were seeing and
i say uh we because there were uh half a
dozen research students uh all
uh in her camp
um
we were discovering
that uh chimps had this capacity for
for violence um the first kill happened
during that time which was of an infant
and a neighboring group
um
and we were starting to see these uh
hunting
expeditions and this was
the start of my interest because it was
such
chilling evidence of
an extraordinary similarity between
chimps
and humans
now at that time
we didn't know very much
about how chimpanzees and humans were
related
chimps gorillas
bonobos are all
three big black hairy things that live
in the african forests and
eat fruits and
leaves when they can't find fruits
and walk on their knuckles and they all
look rather similar to each other so
they seem as though
those three species chimps and gorillas
and bonobos should all be each other's
closest relatives and humans are
something rather separate and so any of
them will be of interest to us
subsequently we learn
that actually that's not true and that
there's a special relationship between
humans and chimpanzees
but at the time
even without knowing that it was obvious
that there was something very odd about
chimpanzees because
jane had discovered they were making
tools
she had seen that they were hunting meat
she had seen that they were sharing the
meat among each other she had seen that
the societies were dominated politically
by males coalitions of males all of
these things of course resonate so
closely with humans
and then it turns out
that
in contrast to conventional wisdom at
the time
the chimpanzees were capable of hunting
and killing members of neighbouring
groups
well
at that point
the similarities between chimps and
humans
become less a matter of
sort of you know sheer intellectual
fascination
than something that has a really deep
meaning about
our understanding of ourselves
i mean until then
you can
cheerfully think of humans as a species
apart from the rest of nature because we
are so peculiar but when it turns out
that
as it turns out one of our two closest
relatives
has got these features that we share
and that one of the features is
something that is the most horrendous
as well as fascinating
aspect of human behavior then you know
how can you resist just
you know trying to find out what's going
on so i have to say this
i'm not sure if you're familiar with a
man but fans of this podcast are so
we're talking about chimps we're talking
about violence my now friend mr joe
rogan
is a big fan of those things i'm a big
fan of these topics i think a lot of
people
are fascinated by these topics so as
you're saying
why
do we
find the exploration of violence and the
relations between chimps so interesting
what can they teach us about ourselves
until we had this information about
chimpanzees
it was possible to believe
that
the
psychology
behind warfare
was
totally the result of some kind of um
cultural recent cultural innovation
right that had nothing to do with our
biology
or if you like that it's got something
to do with uh
sin and and garden
the devil and that sort of thing
but what the chimps tell us
after we
think carefully about it
is that
it seems undoubtedly the case that
our evolutionary psychology
has
given us
the same
kind of attitude towards violence as
has occurred in chimpanzees
and in both species uh it has evolved
because of its uh evolutionary
significance in other words because it's
been helpful to the individuals who have
practiced it
and
now we know that
as i mentioned other species do this as
well
in fact you know wolves
um
which this is a really kind of
ironical
observation
uh conrad lorenz who i mentioned had
been the person who thought that
human
aggression
in the form of killing members of our
own species was unique to our species he
was a great fan of wolves he studied
wolves and in captivity he noted that
wolves are very unlikely to harm each
other in um
spats
among members of the same group
what happens is that one of them will
roll over and present their neck much as
you see in a dog park nowadays and and
the other uh might put their jaws on the
neck but will not bite
okay so now it turns out that if you
studied wolves in the wild
then neighboring packs often go hunting
for each other
they are in fierce competition
and uh as much as 50 of the mortality of
wolves is due to being killed by other
wolves
adult mortality wow so it's a really
serious business
the chimpanzees and humans uh fit into a
larger pattern of understanding animals
in which
you don't have an instinct for violence
what you have is an instinct if you like
to use violence adaptively
and if the right circumstances come up
it'll be adaptive if the right
circumstances don't come up it won't be
so some chimpanzee communities are much
more violent than others because of
things like
the frequency with which a large party
of males is likely to meet us a lone
victim and that's going to depend on the
local ecology
but you know so the overall
answer to the question of what did
chimps teach us is that we have to take
very seriously the notion that in humans
the tendency to
make war
is a consequence of a long-term
evolutionary adaptation and not just a
military ideology or some you know sort
of local patriarchal phenomenon um and
of course you know his a reading of
history a judicious reading of history
fits that very easily because
war is so commonplace
it's not an accident so it's not a
construction of human civilization
it's uh it's deeply within us violence
so what
what's the difference between violence
on the individual level versus group
is um it seems like with chimps and with
wolves there's something about
the dynamic of multiple
uh
chimps together
that increase the chance of violence or
is is violence still
fundamentally part of the individual
like what would an individual be
as violent as they might be as part of a
group
if we're talking about uh killing
okay then um violence in the sense of
killing is very much associated with
a group
and the reason is
that individuals
don't benefit by getting into a fight in
which they risk being hurt themselves
so it's only when you have overwhelming
power
that the temptation to try and kill
another victim
rises
sufficiently for them to be motivated to
do it
the
the average
number of chimpanzee males
that attack a single male
in
something like 50 observations that have
accumulated in the last 50 years
from various different study sites
is eight
eight to one
now sometimes it can go as low as uh
three to one
but that's a that's getting risky
but if you have eight you can see what
can happen i mean basically uh
you have one male on one foot another
male another foot another male and an
arm another male another arm
now you have an immobilized victim
with uh four individuals capable of just
doing the damage and so they can then
move in and tear out his thorax and tear
off his testicles and and twist an arm
until it breaks and uh and do this you
know appalling damage with no weapons
what is uh
the way in which they prefer
to commit the violence
is there something to be said about like
the actual
process of it is there an artistry to it
so if you look at human
warfare
there's different parts in history
preferred different kind of approaches
to violence
it had more to do with tools i think on
the human side but
just the nature of violence itself sorry
the practice the strategy of violence is
it basically the same you improvise you
immobilize the uh
the victim
and they just rip off different parts of
their body kind of thing
yeah you have to understand that
these things are happening at high speed
in thick vegetation yes mostly so that
they
they have not been filmed uh carefully
you know we we have a few
little glimpses of them from uh
one or two people like david watts so
he's got some great video but
uh we don't know enough to be able to to
say that it's hard for me to imagine
that there are styles that vary between
um communities you know cultural styles
but it is possible on one thing that is
striking is that
the
number of times that an individual
victim has been killed immediately
uh has been higher in
uh kibali forest in uganda
than in in gombe national park in
tanzania it's conceivable that's just
chance we don't have real numbers now
but
was this um i can't remember exact
numbers but you know 10 versus
15 or something um
so maybe
they
damage to the point of
uh expecting a death in one place and
they just finish it off in the other but
most likely
that sort of difference will be due to
differences in the numbers of
attackers
you know human beings are able to
conceive of the philosophical notion of
death of mortality is there any of that
for chimps
when they're thinking about violence is
violence like what what is the nature
of their conception of violence do you
think
do they do they realize they're taking
another conscious being's
life or is it some kind of
like optimization over the use of
resources or something like that
i i don't think it's i can't think of
any way to get an answer to the question
of what they know about that um
i think that
uh the way to think about
the motivation
is
uh rather like
the motivation in sex
so
when males are
interested in having sex with a female
whether it's in chimpanzees or in humans
they don't think about the fact that
what this is going to do is to lead to a
baby mostly
you're right mostly what they're
thinking about is i want to get my
underway
and um
i think that that's a similar kind of
process uh with the gems you know what
they are thinking about is i i want to
kill this yes individual
and it's hard to imagine that
taking the other individual's
perspective and thinking about what it
means for them to die is going to be an
important part of that in fact
you know there's reasons to think it
should not be an important part of it
because it might inhibit them and they
don't want to be inhibited you know the
more efficient they are in doing this
the better but you know i think it's
interesting to think about this whole
motivational question because it does
produce a rather haunting thought that
there has been selection in favor of
enthusiasm about killing
and in our
relatively gentle and uh deliberately
moral society that we have today
it's very difficult for us to face the
thought that
in
all of us
there might have been a
a
re
residue and a more than that sort of an
actively uh an active potential
for that thought of really enjoying
killing someone else
but
i i think you know one can sustain that
thought fairly obviously by
thinking of circumstances in which
it would be true
that the ordinary
human male would be delighted to be part
of a group that was killing someone what
you've got to do is to
be in a position where you're regarding
the victim as dangerous
and
thoroughly hostile
but the pure enjoyment of violence
there's uh i don't know if you know this
historian dan carlin he has a podcast he
has an episode
three four hour
episode that i recommend to others it's
quite haunting
but he takes us through an entire
history uh it's called painful tainment
the uh the history of
humans
enjoying the murder of others in a large
group so like public executions were
part of long part of human history
and there's something that
for some reason humans seem to have been
drawn to just watching others die
and he ventures to say that that may
still be part of us for example he said
if it was possible to televise
to stream online for example the
execution and the murder of somebody or
even the torture of somebody
that
a very large fraction of
the population on earth would not be
able to look away they'd be drawn to
that somehow as a very dark
thought
that we were drawn to that
so you think that's part of us in there
somewhere that
selection that we evolved for the
enjoyment of killing and the enjoyment
of observing
uh
those in our tribe
doing the killing
yes i mean and that word you produced at
the end is critical i think you know
because uh
it would be a little bit weird i think
uh to
imagine
a lot of enjoyment about
people in your own tribe being killed
right yeah i i don't think we're
interested in violence for violence's
sake that much
it's um
it's when you get these social
boundaries set up
and
in today's world
you know happily
uh
we kind of are already one world
you know we
you have to dehumanize someone to get to
the point where they are really outside
you know our recognition of a tribe at
some level which is you know the whole
human species
but in
uh ancient times that would not have
been true because in ancient times
there are lots of accounts of hunters
and gatherers uh
in which
the appearance of a stranger
would lead to
an immediate response of
shooting on site
because what was human was the people
that were in your society
and the other things that actually
looked like us and you know were human
in that sense were not regarded as human
so there was a kind of automatic
dehumanization of everybody that didn't
speak our language or hadn't already
somehow become
recognized as uh
sufficiently like us to escape the
the dehumanization context and so
hopefully the story of human history is
that we
are
that tribalism fades away
that our
dehumanization the natural desire to
dehumanize or a tendency to dehumanize
groups that are not within this tribe
decreases over time and so then
the desire for violence decreases over
time yeah i mean that that's the
optimistic perspective and uh and the
the great sort of concern of course is
that
um small conflicts can build up into
bigger conflicts and then dehumanization
happens and then violence is released
as hannah aaron says you know there
currently is no uh known alternative to
war as a means of settling really
important conflicts
so if we look at the big picture what
role has violence or do you think
violence has played in the evolution of
homo sapiens so we are
quite an intelligent got a beautiful
particular little branch on the
evolutionary tree
what part of that
was played by
our tendency to be violent
well i think that violence was
responsible for creating your homo
sapiens
um
and
that raises the question of what homo
sapiens is
yes
yeah exactly
so
you know nowadays people um
begin
the
the concept of what homo sapiens is by
thinking about features that are very
obviously different from all of the
other species of homo
and
our large brain are
a very rounded
cranium a relatively small face
these are characteristics which are
developed in a relatively modern way by
about 170
000 years ago say you know it's one of
the earliest skulls in africa that
really captures that
but uh it has been argued that
that is a
um
an episode in a process
that has been
uh started substantially earlier and
there's no doubt that that's true you
know homo sapiens is a species that has
been changing pretty continuously
throughout
the
length of time it's there
and it goes back to 300 000 years ago
315 literally is the the time
the the best estimate of a date for
uh a series of bones from morocco
that have been dated uh three or four
years ago at that time and have been
characterized as
earliest homo sapiens
now at that point
they are only beginning the trend of
sapionization and that trend consists
basically of grassonization
of making
our ancestors
less robust
shorter faces smaller teeth a smaller
brow ridge a narrower face
a thinner
cranium all these things that are
associated with
reduced violence
okay so that's that's saying what
that's homo sapiens beginning so it
began sometimes three three to four
hundred thousand years ago because by
three hundred fifteen 000 years ago
you've already got something
recognizable so you're you're more on
that side of things that there was this
gradual process it's not 150 170 000
years ago it's
it started like 400 000 years ago and
it's just it started three to four
hundred thousand years ago and and if
you look at 170 it's got even more like
us and if you if you look at at a
hundred it's got more like us again and
if you look at 50 it's more like us
again it's all the way it's just getting
more and more like the moderns
so the question is what happened between
three and four hundred thousand years
ago to produce homo sapiens
and i i think we have a pretty good
answer now
and the answer comes from violence
and the story begins by focusing on this
question why is it that in
the
human species
we are unique among all primates in not
having
an alpha male in any group
in the sense that
what we don't have is an alpha male who
personally beats up
every other male
and the answer
uh that
has been
portrayed most most uh richly by
christopher boehm
and whose work i've elaborated on
uh is that
only in humans
do you have a system by which any male
who tries to bully others
and become the alpha equivalent to an
alpha gorilla or an alpha chimpanzee or
an alpha bonobo or an alpha baboon or
anything like that
any male who tries to do that in humans
gets taken down by a coalition
of beta males
um that coalition yes
it's a really good uh picture of human
society yes i like it okay
so and that's the way all our societies
work now yes um because
individuals try and be alpha and then
they get taken out yeah i mean we don't
usually think of ourselves as beta males
but yes i i suppose i suppose that's
what democracy is
exactly yes exactly
um okay so
well so at some point alpha males get
taken out
well what alpha males are are males who
respond with high reactive violence
to any challenge to their status you see
it all the time in in primates some
peter male thinks he's getting strong
and and uh you know maturing in wisdom
and so on and uh he refuses to
uh kowtow to the alpha male and the
alpha male comes straight in and and
charges at him or maybe he'll just wait
for a few minutes or and then take an
opportunity to attack him
the
um
all of these primates have got a high
tendency for reactive aggression
and that make enables the possibility of
alpha males we don't we have this great
reduction as i talked about earlier
and the question is when did that
reduction happen well
cut to
the famous experiments by the russian
biologist dimitri believe
who tried
domesticating wild animals
when you domesticate wild animals what
you're doing is
reducing reactive aggression
you are selecting those individuals to
breed
who are most willing to be approached by
a human or by another member of their
own species and are least likely to
erupt in a reactive uh aggression
and you only have to do that for a few
generations to discover that there are
changes in the skull
and those changes
consist of
a
shorter face
smaller teeth
a
reduced maleness
are the males become increasingly
female-like
and reduced brain size
well the changes that are characteristic
of domesticated animals in general
compared to wild animals are all found
in homo sapiens compared to our early
ancestors
so it's a very strong signal that when
we first see homo sapiens what we're
seeing is evidence of a reduction in
reactive aggression
and that suggests that what's happening
with homo sapiens is that uh that is the
point at which there is selection
against the alpha males
and therefore
the way in which the selection happened
would have been the way it happens today
the beta males take them out
so i think that
homo sapiens is a species characterized
by
the suppression of reactive aggression
as a kind of incidental consequence of
the suppression of the alpha male
and and the story of our species is the
story of how the beta males took charge
and have been responsible for
the generation of a new kind of human
and incidentally
for
imposing
on the society
a new set of values because when those
beta males discovered that they could
take out the previous alpha male
and continue to do so because in every
generation there'll always be some male
who says
maybe i'll become the alpha male and
they you know so they just keep chopping
them down
in discovering that they also obviously
discovered that they could kill anybody
in the group
females
young males
anybody who
didn't follow their values
and so this story is one of um
one in which the males of our species
and these would be the breeding males
have been able to impose their values on
everybody else and there's two kind of
values there's one kind of value is
things that are good for the group like
thou shalt not murder
and the other kind of value is things
that are good for
the males
such as hey guess what when good food
comes in males get it first yes
so i mean it's fascinating that that
kind of set of ideals could out-compete
the the others
do you have a sense of why
or maybe you can comment on neanderthals
and all the other early humans why did
homo sapiens
come to succeed and flourish and all the
other ones all the other branches
of evolution died out
or get murdered
nowadays when when homo sapiens
meets homo sapiens
and we don't know each other uh
initially
then conflict breaks out and the
more militarily able
group
wins
you know we've seen that
everywhere throughout the age of
exploration and
throughout history
so i'm i'm rather surprised you know the
conventional wisdom uh that you see
nowadays in contemporary anthropology
is very reluctant to point to
uh success in warfare
uh as the reason why sapiens uh wiped
out neanderthals within about 3000 years
of the sapiens coming into europe 43 000
years ago
and
people are much more inclined to say
well the neanderthals were at low
population density so they just couldn't
survive the demographic
sort of
sweep
or the disease came in and you know
maybe those things
might have been important but
you know far and away the most obvious
possibility is that
sapiens were just
were powerful
they had
everyone agrees they had larger groups
they had better weapons uh they they had
uh projectile weapons bows and arrows
to judge from the um little microlith uh
bits of flake
um
which the neanderthals didn't
you know nowadays there's
evidence of of interbreeding uh quite
extensive interbreeding between sapiens
and neanderthals uh as well as with some
other groups and sometimes people say
well you know so they loved each other
they made love not war
i think they made love and war
and
you know it wouldn't necessarily mean
too loving i mean
if you just follow through from
typical ethnographies nowadays of when
um dominant groups meet subordinate
groups they didn't know each other
then uh you can imagine that
neanderthal females would essentially be
captured
and taken into
champions groups
maybe you can comment on this
uh cautiously
and eloquently what's the role of sexual
violence in human evolution because you
mentioned taking
neanderthal females you've also
mentioned that some of these rules are
defined by the
uh by the male side of the society
what's the role of sexual violence in
this story
i think you've got to distinguish
between groups and within groups
and
you know i think where the world has
been slowly waking up over the last
several decades
to the fact that sexual violence is uh
routine in
war
and that to me says
that
um
it's just another example of power
corrupts because uh you know when
frustrated
uh scared
elated
soldiers
uh come upon
females in a group
that has been essential dehumanization
of
then they get carried away by
opportunity
it is
not always possible to argue that this
is adaptive
uh nowadays
because you know you get lots and lots
of stories of um
women being
abused to the point of of being killed
uh you know she'll be gang raped and and
then killed there's lots of
terrible
cases of that reported from all sorts of
different wars
but you can see that that could build on
a
um a pattern that would have been a
adaptive if happening in under
sort of much less extreme circumstances
uh
you know the the war is is very extreme
nowadays in the sense that you get
battles in which people are sent by a
military hierarchy into a war situation
in which they do not feel what hunters
and gatherers would typically have felt
which would have been that if we attack
we have an excellent chance of getting
away with it
nowadays
uh you know you're sent in across the
somme or whatever it is and and there's
a very high chance you will be killed
and that's totally unnatural and a novel
evolutionary experience i think
then there's sexual coercion within
groups
and um
so that takes various kinds of forms
you know but nowadays of course i think
people recognize increasingly that
the principal form of
sexual intimidation
and rape
occurs within relationships
it's not stranger rape that is really
you know statistically important there's
much more
um what happens
behind the walls
of
a bedroom where people have been living
for some time
and
um
just two sort of you know thoughts and
observations about this uh one is that
it may seem odd
that
um
that males should be
i
should think it
you know a good idea as it were to
impose themselves sexually on someone
with whom they have a relationship
but what they're doing is
intimidating someone
in a relationship in which the relative
power in the relationship has continuing
significance uh for a long time
and that power probably goes well beyond
uh just the sexual you know it's it's to
do with domestic relationships it's to
do with
the man getting his his own way all the
way it's power dynamics and uh the
sexual aggression is one of the tools to
regain power gain power gain more power
and that kind of thing yeah
exactly and and in that respect
um it's worth noting that
although this wasn't appreciated uh for
some time it's it's emerging that in a
bunch of primates you have somewhat
similar
somewhat parallel kinds of sexual
intimidation
where males will target particular
females even in a
group in which the norm is for females
to mate with multiple males
but each male will target a particular
female and
the more he is aggressive towards her
then the more she
conforms to his wishes when he wants to
mate
so a long-term pattern of sexual
intimidation
so there's that aspect the other aspect
i would just just note is that
males
get away with a lot compared to females
in the any kind of intersexual conflict
um
you know so the punishment uh
here's one example of this the
punishment for a husband killing a wife
uh has always been much less than the
punishment for a wife killing a husband
um and and you see similar sorts of
things in terms of the punishments for
adultery and um
and so on and
i bring this up in the context of
of males
sexually intimidating uh their partners
may be wives or or whoever
because it's a reminder that
it's basically a patriarchal world that
we have come from
a patriarchal world in which
male alliances
tend to support males
and take advantage of the fact that they
have political power at the expense of
females
and i would say that that all goes back
to what happened three to four hundred
thousand years ago
when the beta males took charge and they
started imposing their own norms on
society as a whole and they've continued
to do so and you we now look at
ourselves and you know jordan peterson
says we are not a patriarchal society
well you know it's true that the laws
try and make it even-handed nowadays
between males and females but obviously
we are patriarchal de facto
because society still in many ways uh
supports
um
men better than it supports women in
these sorts of conflicts so beta male
patriarchal
[Laughter]
if we're looking
at the evolutionary history okay is
there uh maybe sticking on jordan for a
second is is there
um
so he's a psychologist right and
what part of the picture do you think
he's missing in analyzing
the human relations
like what needs what does he need to
understand
about our origins and violence and the
way the society has been constructed oh
i i don't want to
go deep into into his
missing perspectives you know but i just
think that
um
that what he's doing in that particular
example is
uh focusing on the legalistic position
and that's great
that um you know you do not find
uh formal patriarchy in the law anything
like to the extent that you could find
it 100 years ago
and so on you know women have got the
vote now hooray but it took a long time
for women to get the vote
and um you know it remains the case
that
um
the women
suffer in in various uh kinds of ways
you know you know
a woman who is
uh has lots of sexual partners uh is uh
treated much more rudely than a male who
has lots of sexual partners
uh there are all sorts of informal ways
in which uh it's a rougher being a woman
than it is a man
and uh if we look at
the surface layer
of uh the law
we may miss the deeper
human nature
uh
like the origins of our human nature
that still operates no matter what the
law says yeah
which is
you know human nature is awkward because
uh it includes
some unpleasant features that uh when we
sit back and reflect about them uh we
would like to
uh them to go away yeah
but it remains the fact that
men
are
hugely concerned to try and
have sex with
um
at least one woman and you know often
lots of women yeah and so women are con
men are constantly putting pressure on
women in
ways that women find unpleasant and if
men sit back and reflect about it they
think yeah we shouldn't do this but
actually just it just goes on because of
human nature
so maybe looking at particular humans in
history uh let's talk about genghis khan
so
is uh this particular human who was
one of the most famous examples of
a large-scale violence is he a deep
representative of human nature or is he
a rare exception
well
i think that
it's easy to imagine that
most men could have become genghis khan
uh
it's possible that he had a particular
streak of psychopathy
um
you know it's it's striking that
i by the time you become
[Music]
immensely powerful
then uh your
willingness
to do terrible things
uh for the interest of yourself and your
group
becomes
very high
you know
stalin
marty tung
these sorts of people
have histories
in which they do not show
obvious psychopathy but by the time they
are big leaders they are really
psychopathic in the sense that
they do not follow the ordinary morality
of considering
the harm that they are doing to their
victims
i
you know what kind of experiment would
we need to discover whether or not
anybody could fall into this position i
don't know
but
you know lord acton's uh famous dictum
was
power corrupts an absolute power
corrupts absolutely
and then the point that people often
forget is the next sentence that he said
which is great men are almost always bad
men
and that is right
it is very difficult to find a great man
in history who was not responsible for
terrible
things i think there's some aspect of it
that it's not just power
i think
men who's been who have been the most
destructive in human history
are not psychopathic
completely
they have convinced themselves of an
idea it's like the idea of psychopathic
uh stalin for example i don't hitler is
a complicated one i think he was
legitimately insane but i think stalin
has convinced himself that
he's doing good
so the idea of communism is the thing
that's psychopathic in his mind like a
bread you construct a worldview in which
the violence is justified the cruelty is
justified so they're
in in that
sense first of all you can construct
experiments unethical experiments that
could test this but
uh
in that sense anybody else could have
been in stalin's position
it's the idea that could overtake the
mind of a human being
and in so doing justify cruel acts and
that seems to be at least in part unique
to humans
is the ability to hold ideas in our
minds
and share those ideas
and
use those ideas to convince ourselves
that
uh proactive violence on a large scale
is a good idea
so that i i don't know if you haven't
supposed though i mean but but uh
it seems to me what really motivated my
uh stalin was not so much
uh
communism uh as
the retention of power
so once he became
leader
and in the process of becoming leader
he was absolutely desperate to get rid
of anybody who was a challenger he was
deeply suspicious suspicious of of
anybody uh even on his side
uh who might possibly be showing a
glimmerings of uh willingness to
challenge him
so you know when he uh
apparently had uh uh kirov uh murdered
uh kirov was a great communist
uh trotsky was a great communist
uh you know all all his rivals uh and i
mean when he went into the towns and and
murdered people by the tens of thousands
they were all communists a lot of them
were coming
explicit communists that's right but but
what he was worried about was that there
were rivals to him
i suppose the thought is
i am the best person to bring about
a uh
a global
sort of embrace of communism and others
are not
and so we have to get rid of those
others well i suspect you're being very
charitable here but i mean
maybe you're
you know enough about starting to
realize
well so the point i'm making i i do
quite a bit
is
from my
understanding and sense of course we
can't know for sure is he believed in
communism this wasn't purely a game
of power now he got drunk with power
pretty quickly
but
he really believed for
i believe his whole life that
uh communism is good for the world
and that i don't know what role
that belief plays with the not more
natural
human desire for power
i don't know but it just seems like as
we agreed he's killing a lot of
communists on his
on his journey
hmm
but it's not that doesn't that calculus
doesn't work that way there's
humans who are communists and then
there's the idea of communism so
for him in his delusional worldview
killing a few people
is
worth the final result of bringing
communism to the whole world
but it was more than that again because
i mean he really wanted power for uh the
soviet union and and uh so surely the
reason that he um
he uh orchestrated the
export of
wheat from ukraine and in so doing was
willing to lead to mass starvation was
because he wanted to sell it on the
market in order to be able to build up
the power of
the soviet union
you know alternative view of communism
might have been well you know
let's just make sure everybody survives
and make sure everybody has enough to
eat and we'll all be mutually supportive
in a communal network but no but he
wanted the power for the country well i
guess exactly so that it's not even
communism the set of ideas or like
marxism or something like that it's the
country i guess what i'm saying is uh
it's not
purely power for the individual
it's power for a vision for this great
nation
the soviet union yeah and similar with
hitler
the guy believed
that this is a great nation germany and
like they it it's a nation that's been
wronged throughout history and needs to
be righted
and there's some
dance between the individual human and
the tribe yes no absolutely yes and so
so just like chimpanzees uh you know we
are fiercely tribal
and the tribalism uh resides
particularly in male psychology
and uh it's it's very scary because once
you assemble
a
set of males who
share tribal identity then they have
power that they can exert
with
very little
concern about what they're doing to
damage other people
do you think this
so nietzsche
will to power
we talked about the corrupting nature of
power do you think that's a
manifestation
of those
uh early origins of violence
what's the connection of this desire for
power
and our proclivity for violence
you know what we're talking about is um
tribal power right power on behalf of a
group yes and uh yeah that seems to me
to go right back to
a deep evolutionary origin
because you see essentially the same
thing in uh in a whole bunch of animals
you know they that most
uh of the sort of
cognitively complex animals live in
social groups in which they have tribal
boundaries
and
so what you see in chimpanzees is echoed
in almost all of the primates the
difference between
us and
chimpanzees and humans on the one hand
and other primates on the other
is that we kill and they don't and the
reason they don't is because
they never meet in the context where
there are massive imbalances of power
so
two groups of baboons you know there's
30 on
this side and 50 on this side fine
nobody's going to try and kill anybody
else because
the serious risks involved
but nevertheless they are tribal so
you know they will have
fairly intense intergroup interactions
uh
in which everybody knows whose side is
on who is on whose side and um
the long-term consequences of
winning those battles non-lethal battles
is that the dominance i get access to
larger areas of land
more safety and so on with chances are
better
record of
reproductive success subsequently
do you think this from an evolutionary
perspective is a feature or a bug our
natural
sort of tendency to form tribes
so what's a bug
oh sorry this is a computer uh
programming analogy
meaning like
it would be more beneficial
is it beneficial or detrimental
to form tribes from an evolutionary
perspective yeah yeah but but but
what is that what does it mean what does
a bug mean yes right i mean
well yeah it's like where's evolution
going it's beneficial from you know it's
beneficial in the sense that it evolved
by natural selection
to be to benefit the individuals who did
it yes but if you if by bug you mean
something that from the point of view of
the species it would be great if you
could just wipe this out right because
the species would somehow do better yes
as a result
then yes but but then you know males are
a bug
oh come on now it's uh
there's some nice things to males
uh speaking as a male i the fact that
there are some nice things to males
doesn't mean that they're not bugs you
know maybe they're quite nice bugs but
it'll be much better for the species as
a whole not to have to have males who
impose this violence on the species as a
whole yeah
as somebody who practiced controlled
violence and doing a lot of martial arts
yeah it uh i'm not sure
it does seem kind of fun to have this
kind of controlled violence also sports
also i mean the question of conflict in
general i guess that's the deeper
question
don't you think there's some value to
conflict
for the improvement of society for
progress that that this tension between
tribes
isn't this
like
uh experiment
a continued experiment will conduct with
each other to figure out what is a
better world to build like you need that
conflict
of good ideas and bad ideas
to go to war with each other it's like
the united states with the 50 states and
the it's the laboratory of ideas
don't you think that is again feature
versus bug
um it
this kind of conflict when it doesn't
get out of hand
is actually ultimately progressive
productive for a better world
well what do you mean by conflict
i mean you can have conflict in the
sense of people have different ideas
about the solution to a problem and so
their ideas are in conflict they can sit
down with it and uh
on a log and chat about it and then
decide okay you're right or i'm wrong or
whatever
um
but but if by conflict uh you mean a
great idea to build a nuclear bomb and
set that off
then
no you know i don't see why it's a good
idea to have all this violence
yeah there's
i i wonder
i mean it's not a good idea but i wonder
if human history would evolve the way it
did without the violence
oh i'm sure you're you're right probably
uh humans would not have evolved in in
the sense that we have
but i would hope that
uh the course of
uh
violence
in evolution will continue in the way it
has
so
you know there's all sorts of
indications um
that the
importance of violence has been reduced
over time
and you know this is
made famous in stephen pinker's book but
others have written about it too
that the the frequency of uh death from
violence
in every country you look at
has been declining
that's just great and so you know the
amazing thing about this is that even
when you take the death due to the first
world war and the second world war the
20th century appears to have been
statistically meaning rates of death per
individual
the
least violent
in history
so we haven't got very far down the
course to non-violence but i don't see
why we shouldn't just carry on doing it
i think it's ridiculous frankly you know
excuse my frankness uh to to say that uh
violence is a good thing
um i think that it would be a wonderful
concept if we could evolve somehow to a
world you know 3 000 years from now
where violence is really regarded as uh
simply appalling and that you know they
look back on our time and can't believe
what we were doing
yeah
but of course violence takes a lot of
different shapes as we start to think
deeper and deeper about living
beings on earth for example the violence
would commit and the torture would
commit to animals and then perhaps down
the line as we talked offline about is
with robots
and that kind of thing so there there's
just so many ways to commit violence to
others and some people now talk about
violence in the space of ideas
which of course to me at least is a bit
of a silly notion relative to use that
same v word for the space of ideas
versus actual physical violence but it
may be that a long time from now we see
that even violence in the space of ideas
is is quite a manifestation of that same
kind of violence and so it is
interesting where this is headed and i
think you're absolutely right
a world
a non-violent world does seem like a
better world i wonder if the constraints
on resources
somehow make that world
more and more difficult especially as we
run out of resources well it's got to be
very very different from what we're
doing nowadays
and it's unimaginably different if we
could imagine it then maybe we could
work towards it at the moment nobody
knows how to work towards it well that's
kind of the stories of humans as we we
don't really know the future we're
trying to try to add hog kind of
develop it as we go and sometimes get
into trouble yeah that's the violence
but it you know george orwell's vision
in 1984 was of
of you know two or three world powers
each so powerful that nobody could
could diminish the
could destroy the other
but the notion of
an evolutionarily stable relationship
among
heavily armed world powers
just does not seem
as though
it's reasonable at all
that's to say
uh you know we've we've now got
170 or 190 nations in the world
uh dominated by a few big ones
uh all with arms pointing at each other
and the notion that we could just carry
on having peace talks and making sure
that uh these arms uh don't get uh
involved in some kind of massive
confrontation
seems incredibly optimistic
some kind of major change has to happen
uh whereby
you know and some people would like to
see all the weapons go that'd be great
you know i i'm a
member of that that sort of group that
tries to to see that happen
it's going to be very difficult to see
it happen
um another kind of concept is
the nations themselves will dissolve and
will become
one
one government
that itself is a terrifying vision
because the capacity for abuse by a
single world power would be
so problematic and in addition how do
you get there without a war in the first
place
so you know at the moment we we have
no reasonable kind of future in mind but
i'm sure it's there somewhere it's just
that we haven't yet to find it and a lot
of people like in the cryptocurrency
space argue that you can create
decentralized societies if you take away
the power from states to define the
monetary system so they argue like if
you give if if you make the monetary
system such that it's disjoint from
anyone the control of any one individual
any one government then that might be a
way to form sort of ad-hoc decentralized
societies just they just pop up all over
the place that's a really interesting
technological uh solution to how to
remove the overreach of power from
governments yeah that's right absolutely
and and it may well be that uh
that
the future will emerge out of some sort
of quite surprising
direction uh like that is it
nevertheless surprising to you that we
have not destroyed ourselves with
nuclear weapons so the mutually assured
destruction that we've had for many
decades from somebody who studies
violence
how does that make sense to you well i
mean i'm surprised only in the sense
that um accidental the the the fact that
we have not had an accident yet
uh has been quite remarkable
yeah because all the accounts are that
we've come very close to having very
serious accidents where
people either side of misread
intentions or apparent launches and so
on
uh so yes i think it is remarkable there
is a a nasty
um
generalization that can be made that uh
the longer that um powerful states go
uh without having wars then the worst
the war is afterwards
and you know you can sort of see that
that kind of makes sense because
basically what's happening uh with these
tribal groups that the nations are at
the moment
is that
after a big war like the second world
war
they established new kinds of dominance
relationships
and then
during the periods of peace what happens
is that
the
de facto dominance relationships change
because some nations become poorer some
become richer some become more
militarily powerful and so on generally
economy and military goes hand in hand
so you know right now china uh emerged
from the war is a relatively low status
state and is now high status so if this
were chimpanzees you know what would
happen is that you would predict a
conflict because you need to have a
readjustment of the formal dominance
relationships to recognize the the new
in practice dominance relationships
recognized by the economy in the
military
so the longer that you have of a period
of peace following a war then the more
these tensions of unresolved changed
dominance relationships build up
and the longer they take to occur then
uh the more uh challenging uh are going
to be the conflicts that's a terrifying
view because we've been we've been out
of conflict for quite a bit that's right
maybe it's building up
so it's a scary view but on the other
hand you know things have changed hugely
with the
advent of nuclear weapons because at
least that
conforms to
this psychology that is very clear in
other animals which is you don't want to
get into a fight if you are going to get
hurt
so that's the whole principle of mad
mutually assured destruction
and it's doubtless being why
powerful nations like america and
and russia
have not used their nuclear weapons
since 1945
the you know so
if we can overcome the problem of
accidental launches
then maybe the fact of mad does fit into
human psychology in a way that means
that we really will resolve our tensions
without using them but
we haven't yet really faced that
challenge you know i mean the soviet
union collapsed because of uh the poor
economy but with
china you know desperate to
take back taiwan
and
america shifting its focus on the
pacific
the potential for something going wrong
is clearly very high
so what's the
hopeful case that you can make for a
long-term surviving and thriving human
civilization
given all the dangers that we face
well i i can't really exactly make one i
would just say that
we're talking about the dangers
obviously the dangers are there yeah um
but but what i would
sort of think about is um
the notion that
that surprises
come from all sorts of different
directions
you know and um i mean
you you're you work in robotics and you
know i can well imagine that
there will be advances in robotics and
in some way i can't even conceive will
somehow undermine
the
motivation for conflict
something about
you know by the time chips have been
planted in human brains and we're all
instantly sharing information in a way
that we never did before
will this change the nature of
uh human existence in such a way that
these conflicts
get resolved so remove the conflicts but
keep some of the magic the beauty of
what it means to be human so like still
be able to enjoy life the richness of
life the full complexity of life because
you can remove conflict by giving
everybody a pill
and then they go to sleep right you
still want life to be amazing
uh exciting you know uh
interesting and so that's where you have
to find the balance
well it's
yes i mean it's all science fiction
stuff and and uh so how it's going to
work out totally unclear
um
i don't see any worry about the magic of
life disappearing i mean
first of all you somehow get rid of
males i think i think you really need to
get rid of males because males are the
source of
uh
of of a major problem which is the lust
for power
and the resulting conflict but you don't
think the males are also a source of
beauty
and creation no no i mean i i i don't
have anything against males as you know
as individuals that sort of thing and
and males have clearly done a lot i mean
they've been incredibly exploratory and
creative
and what they've done in in art and
music has been wonderful and that sort
of thing
on the other hand
i'm not sure there's anything
particularly special and i think that
probably females could do the same thing
just as well when given the chance
yes including the dark stuff i i mean a
partial part of me is not understanding
the
so there is
a evolutionary distinction between men
and women
but
i tend to believe both men and women if
you look out into the future can be
destructive can be evil can be greedy
can be corrupted by power so if you move
males from the picture which are
historically connected to this evolution
of that we've been talking about
that women are going to fill that role
quite nicely and then it'll be just
the same kind of process we not the same
but it'll be new
and
interesting
there's a there's a sense that the the
will to power
craving power committing violence is
somehow coupled
with the
with all the things that are beautiful
about life
that if you remove conflict completely
if you remove all the evil in the world
it it
it seems like
you're going to um
you're not going to have a stable place
for the beauty for the goodness like
there's always has to be
a dragon to fight
for the way if you look at human history
now you can say
the the reason i'm nervous about a sort
of utopia where everything is great
is every time you look through human
history when utopia has been chased you
run into a lot of trouble or again
sneaks into this evil this craving for
power now you could say that's a male
problem
but i just think it's a human problem
and it's not even a human problem it's a
chimp problem too it's life on earth
problem intelligent life on earth
problem so like it's better to um
not necessarily get rid of the sources
of the darker sides of human nature but
more create mechanisms that
the kindness the the goodness as
the goodness paradox your book
that that
is
incentivized
and encouraged empowered
well
look
i don't think it would be utopia if you
got rid of the males
right
and certainly females capable of
conflict
i just think it's a gamble worth taking
if you could actually do it
you can certainly find females in
history who've done unpleasant things
but nevertheless
you know we have a very strong
evolutionary theory which explains why
males benefit more
by
having conflict and winning conflicts
than females do
and
so
if we want to talk about reducing
conflict yes then
it would reduce it to get rid of males
now i understand this is a fantasy yeah
and it i think it's a fantasy that
people would be able to talk about
fairly soon because reproductive
technology is getting to the point where
it's quite likely that
human females could breed without the
use of males
and so
there would be a sort of
a potential dynamic
if
everybody just agreed not to have any
male babies
it's a it's a really interesting thought
experiment i will agree with you that
if given two buttons one is get rid of
all women
and the other buttons get rid of all men
um
realizing that uh
i have a stake in this uh choice uh
you're probably getting rid of all men
if i wanted to preserve
earth
and the richness of life on earth i
would probably get rid of all men i
don't know i don't think you ever stake
in it you know i mean
but you're saying that because you're a
man yeah but i don't see why being a man
should make you any more interested in
having a male future for the world than
a female future you know you've got just
as many ancestors who were male as as
were female
well my problem is i'll have to die
well that's going to happen anyway
i know but like i prefer to die tomorrow
not today you know i you know i prefer
to snooze hit the snooze button on the
whole mortality thing but it's
interesting but this is not suggesting
that males have to die in order to make
room for females it's just
you know you you all you have to do is
just say
don't let's have any more males born
interesting of course you know the
difficulty is that that because we're
tribal you know some country somewhere
would say well we're not going to do
that yeah and then guess what they'd
take over yeah because they're male so
that's why it's impossible to imagine
actually happening
uh you know what i'm gonna i'm gonna
take that and actually think about it i
don't know i'm uncomfortable
there's a
there's a certain kind of woke culture
that i've been kind of uncomfortable
with because
it's not women necessarily it's more
just
there's a lot of bullying i see
there's a lack of empathy and a lack of
kindness towards others that's created
by that culture so but you're speaking
about something else you're speaking
about
reducing conflict in this world
and looking at the basics of our
human nature and its origins
in the uh
evolution of homo sapiens and thinking
about which kind of
aspects of human nature if we get rid of
them we'll make for a better world
it's an interesting thought experiment
but it is only a thought experiment i
mean you know it's got no practical
meaning uh right now yeah and and i take
your point that
um
you know males get a hard rap nowadays
uh in some ways because
uh the balance of uh social power
is moving
uh
against
um i mean you know quite rightly in a
strong sense of course against
all the nasty things that males do
but
what people sometimes fail to remember
is that um
life is very hard for males who
don't have the power
who
don't have money
who don't have
access to women
you know i'm sympathetic to uh in cells
i
i'm not sympathetic
to them using violence to solve their
problems
but i am very sympathetic to the fact
that
it's not easy simply to be told by
um
well-off
um
feminist
uh middle-class people
uh that you shouldn't behave like this
or you shouldn't feel like this because
you do yes
that's who you are i mean the the in
general just empathy and kindness
male or female i
have uh i believe
will be the thing that builds a better
world and that
that's practiced in different ways from
different backgrounds but ultimately you
should listen to others and empathize
with the experience of others and put
more love out there in the world now
that's hopefully is the way to reduce
conflict
uh reduce violence
and uh
reduce that that whole psychological
experience of being powerless in this
world problems to become the best
version of yourself
and that you know but no one's going to
disagree with all those fine sentiments
right but that
yes but that's that's an actionable
thing is actually practice empathy
right like saying that um
somebody should be silenced or just like
this group is bad and this group is good
i just feel like that's not empathy
empathy is
understanding
the experience of others and like
respecting it
like i mean that that's that's what it
that's what a better world looks like
that's what the reduction of conflict
looks like
it's like as opposed to uh
saying my tribe is right your tribe is
wrong
uh forget the violence and non-violence
part that just that act of saying my
tribe is right that tribe is wrong
removing that from the picture that's
the way to make a better world
that's the way to reduce the violence i
think
not necessarily removing the people who
are
causing the violence you have to get to
the source of the problem i don't mean
the evolutionary source but
the just the
the mindset
that creates the violence is usually
just a lack of empathy
for others
yeah but you know i mean you can't just
teach that because there's our
evolutionary psychology
puts us in particular directions so you
don't think
do you think it's possible to learn
through practice
to resist the basics of our evolutionary
psychology the basic forces
yeah i mean lots and lots of training
you know lots and lots of education
uh can do it the
the famously most peaceful society uh
that anthropologists have recorded uh
involves a tremendous amount of
of teaching
including some punishment
you know it's a society in thailand
you you have to beat it out of children
to make them nice so it's carrot and
steak
you know the point is that
you do not find societies in which
people are spontaneously
showing the kinds of
behaviors that we would all love them to
show it requires work it requires work
what is your book titled goodness
paradox what are the main ideas in this
book
well the paradox is the fact that humans
show
extremes
in relationship to both violence and
non-violence
and
the violence is that we are one of these
few animals in which we
use coalitionary proactive violence to
kill members of our own species and we
do it in large numbers just like a few
other species
and the
non-violence is were particularly
extreme in
how
repressed we are in terms of reactive
violence and i i told you the story of
of how we get there you know so what's
so extraordinary about us is that
uh most animals uh are either high on
both or relatively low on both
so chimpanzees are high on proactive
violence and reactive violence bonobos
are less
than
chimpanzees on both of those but still
hundreds of times more
reactively aggressive than humans are
what we've done is retain
uh proactive violence being high and got
a reactive violence really being low
and so we have these wonderful societies
in which we're all so incredibly nice to
each other and tolerant and calm and and
can meet strangers and have no problem
about um
leading to any kind of conflict
at the same time as we are one of the
worst killing machine species that's
never existed so what's so extraordinary
about this is that if you look at the
political philosophers of the last few
hundred years
you've got this fight
famously between thomas hobbes and
jean-jacques rousseau or literally
you've got the fight between their
followers
you know so the followers of hobbes say
well hobbes was right because he says
that we are naturally violent and you
need a leviathan a central government or
a king to be able to suppress the
violence
so we're naturally hurried and we can
learn to be good whereas jean-jacques
rousseau is interpreted as saying the
opposite that we are naturally good and
it's only when culture intervenes and
and horizontal ideologies come in that
we become uncivilized and so people have
have had this endless fight between are
we naturally
corrupt
or are we naturally uh kind
and and that has gone on you know for
years and it's only in the last two or
three decades that anthropologists like
christopher bohm and bruce naft have
said look you know it's obvious what the
answer is we are both of these things
and what is so exciting now is i think
we can understand why we are both and
the answer is we come from ancestors
that were elevated on proactive
aggression that were
hunters and killers
both of animals and of each other
i think you've got to include that as
almost certain uh from the past
and um and then now we've we've
taken our reactive aggression and we've
down regulated it and that's given us
power it's given us power because
once you get rid of the alpha male once
the beta males take over and
force selection in favor of a more
tolerant less reactively aggressive
individual
the effect is
that our cultures suddenly become
capable of focusing on things other than
conflict
and so we have social groups in which
individuals instead of constantly being
on edge in the way that chimpanzees are
with each other
um
are able to interact
in ways that enable them to share
looking at a tool together or share
their food together or
pass ideas from one to another or
support each other when they're ill or
whatever the issue is cooperate in ways
that make the group
far more effective so you asked earlier
you know what did i think about why
sapiens was able to expand at the
expense of neanderthals so dramatically
around 40 000 years ago and the answer
is uh
that
whatever it was it had something to do
with the sapiens ability to cooperate
yeah that was what gave them bigger
groups that's what enabled them to
have a far more effective way of living
and i suspect it was to do with the
weapons and and military aspects but
even if it wasn't that the the
greater cooperation that sapiens were
showing uh would have been hugely
important so sapiens then had groups of
uh
you know who knows exactly how big they
were but um
uh
scores of of people uh to judge from
their remains uh whereas the
neanderthals were living in um widely
separated small groups of you know maybe
maybe as many as 15 or 20 people
sometimes um
where they saw others so rarely that
they were inbreeding at high levels you
know fathers
uh having babies with their daughters
very different world
very different world and that's probably
what our world was like before we got
sapiens before we got serpents and it's
fascinating that there was that kind of
violence against so
once you get the
get rid of the alpha males
you have now the freedom to uh
to have kindness amongst the beta
the beta males like not not kindness but
collaboration that's the better word yes
right much more correlation not just
among the males but among the beta males
but also among the gamma males and
the uh and the females yeah
i don't know what a gamma male is but i
imagine there's a whole alphabet
well i don't know about hill alphabet
but i think the the big letters are the
married men yeah and and the and the
unmarried men ah you know because now
the married men were had a problem with
the unmarried men
right i mean you you see it in
ethnographies of hunters and gatherers
recently where uh the unmarried men
would be given rules such as i mean the
very extreme rule in northern australia
was uh you cannot come to the camp uh
for months you have to go away and live
uh somewhere out in the bush yes because
we don't want you anywhere near our
wives
and and then another kind of you know
rule is um if you are in camp you must
be in the fire light all the time
otherwise we don't know what you're
doing out in the dark
so you're real enough to control them
because you know
the men who had lots of wives did not
want those horrid bachelors sneaking
around the piece
i love this you also wrote the book
titled catching fire how cooking made us
human
what's the central idea in this book
the subtitle how cooking made us human
refers not to homo sapiens but to homo
erectus so human there means the genus
homo
and homo erectus is the first
full member of the genus homo in the
sense that
it looked like us just with a sort of
slightly robust more robust build and a
smaller brain
i and the central idea of catching fire
is that it was the um control of fire
that
was responsible for the emergence of
homo erectus
and therefore the genus
homo
which happened two million years ago
and it was
a
an evolution from
a
um a line of australopithecines
and australopithecines are the creatures
from whom
we evolved
they
were present in africa
from something like
six or seven million years ago
up to um actually up to one million
years ago
and then a branch
led off to homo around 2 million years
ago
and the way to think of
australopithecines
is that they were like chimpanzees
standing upright
so they were erect bipedal walkers
they were like chimpanzees
in the sense that uh they had brains
about the size of a chimpanzee they were
literally about the body size of a
chimpanzee a little bit smaller actually
and they had big jaws because they were
still eating
raw food they had
big teeth and big jaws
and then around two million years ago
the line of australopithecines which
ended with a an intermediate species a
kind of missing link area because it's
not
missing called
habilis
sometimes called homo habilis but more
properly i in my view call
australopithecus habilis
that
gave rise to homo erectus
and homo erectus here's how different it
was
it had
a smaller mouth
a smaller jaw
smaller teeth
and to judge from its ribs and pelvis
smaller gut
in addition
it had lost what australopithecines all
had which was adaptations for climbing
in the trees
and that meant that homo erectus must
have slept on the ground
and since it slept on the ground
it should have been able to defend
itself somehow against predators and i
can't think of any way they could have
done that unless they had fire
so
there are two major clues to why
it was
with homo erectus
that our ancestors first acquired the
control of fire
one is the fact that they were clearly
not sleeping in trees in the way that
chimpanzees and gorillas and bonobos and
all the other primates do
and the other is that
there was this
striking reduction throughout the gut
reduction in
size of the mouth and the chewing
apparatus
and in the gut itself
and
that
conforms to what we see nowadays about
humans which is that our guts are about
two-thirds of the size of what they
would be if we at raw food
to judge by
the great apes
so
at some point in our revolution
we
acquired
the skill of cooking and skill of
controlling fire
at no time
between two million years ago and the
present
do we see any changes in our anatomy
that can as it were justify
uh the
enormous change that happens when
you are an animal that learns to control
fire
but at two million years ago we have
exactly what you'd expect namely the
guts becoming smaller because the food
is becoming softer and much more easy to
digest so you don't have to work so hard
in your body to digest it
and as i say a commitment to sleeping on
the ground
which i think you'd be absolutely crazy
to do nowadays uh on a moonless night uh
in the middle of serengeti unless you
had fire i've slept out quite a lot in
various parts of africa uh in the bush
and you will not catch me
just lying on the ground um in an area
with lots of predators unless i got a
fire with me you're going to get eaten
you're going to get terrified and you're
going to get eaten
okay so there's a million questions i
want to ask so one
is is it very naturally coupled the
discovery of controlled fire and
cooking with fire is that an obvious
leap
well what here's what we know we know
that um all the animals that we've
tested like to eat their food cooked
more than they like it raw okay so this
is true for all the great apes you know
we've tested them
um that's fascinating by the way why is
that that's just like a property of food
i suppose yes i think what it is is that
um
animals are always looking for any kind
of way to get food that is easier to
digest
and there are various signals in the
food such as the amount of sugar there
the amount of free amino acids because
the amino acids can be tasted
and the physical qualities of the food
be particularly important how tough the
food is always prefer softer food
provided it it feels safe you know it
tastes safe
and these kinds of sensory cues
are
all there in cooked food
you know it's uh it's soft it doesn't
have so many uh toxins it's not so
noxious to taste um easier to chew
so
everyone loves it spontaneously uh your
dogs and your cats prefer cooked food or
raw food well maybe you can say that's
the consequence of domestication but
even you know as i say all of the great
apes
not you test naive ones and uh they
prefer it cooked if they can so
so then obvious once you have fire
you're going to accidentally discover
that
food changes when you apply fire to it
and then there's going it's going to be
the crate the big crazy new fad yeah you
took the words out of my mouth i mean if
if they have fire at all and you know
their food rolls into it
five minutes later it tastes better than
before
how big of an invention from an
engineering perspective do you think is
the discovery of fire
do you think
for the
uh for homo erectus homo sapiens do you
think it's the greatest invention ever
yeah
i think i think that
that
the control of fire has
been ultimately responsible for
essentially
how grandiose do i want to be here you
know the entire human story uh going
back to homo it is what changed us from
being a regular kind of animal
and
perhaps the biggest way in which it is
likely to have changed this is
it reduced
the difficulty of making a large brain
so
you know the story here is that
the constraints on brain size
are energetic
you and i have brains that are something
like
2.5
of our body weight
uh it consumes around 25
of all of our calories
so it's disproportionate
there are other expensive organs in our
body as well such as the heart
and
what's different about their brain is
that in addition to us being able to
fuel it in a way that other animals
can't
we also have reasons for wanting to have
an even bigger brain whereas we don't
want an even bigger heart
so what those reasons are is unclear but
with regard to the costs of maintaining
a brain
cooking makes it possible because it's
supplying
more calories
and it is enormously reducing the amount
of time that it takes to chew your food
so if you were a gorilla
and you wanted to have a bigger brain
you might say okay well let's just eat
some more
but gorillas are eating
for
pretty much the entire day in the sense
that they are eating for
maybe seven or eight hours a day in in
some seasons
uh that's just chewing and then they've
got to sit around and digest their food
because they can't just eat all the time
they've got to
take a break while the food is
digested in the stomach and then passed
into the gut
so the stomach is already full
so basically gorillas are eating about
the maximum rate already
so how does a gorilla get a bigger brain
it doesn't it's actually got a smaller
brain relative to his body size than
chimpanzee does
and um
and that's the basic problem for our
ancestors then you come along and cook
and all of a sudden you can get an
increased amount of energy from your
food
you are spending much less energy on
digesting your food
you know there are
25 bodily processes
or more that are involved in digesting
your food making the acid that
takes the proteins apart
maintaining the brush border where the
molecules are taken across the gut wall
and so on
that all costs it costs you to digest
your food it costs less if you cook your
food so you get a net gain in the amount
of energy
and you are reducing the amount of time
from
uh in our case of our ancestors probably
around fifty percent of the day
to chewing to nowadays
one hour a day chewing
so all of a sudden you've got hours a
day in which to do other things and to
use those those brains that you've now
enabled to grow so with homo erectus you
start the process of getting a bigger
brain and famously you know throughout
the whole period of the evolution of the
genus homo you have a steadily
increasing size of brain
until
right at the end when it actually gets
smaller but that's a different story
which end is this
which are we talking about homo sapiens
yeah in with homo sapiens you've got a
smaller brain uh from
um people haven't got it exactly down
but at least 30 000 years ago it starts
declining
and
so the fascinating thing about that is
that all domesticated animals have
smaller brains than their wild ancestors
and
i
the domestication is intricately
connected to this brain size you think
and do yeah exactly so i think what
we're seeing in humans is uh is that
same manifestation um and then the
fascinating question is is why and the
only point i would want to make about
this is
that there's no evidence that in the
small brain domesticates they're losing
say an average about 15 percent of brain
size
uh in those small brain domestics
compared to their wild ancestors there's
no indication of a loss of
cognitive ability
so i think what's going on is that
uh it's a it's a younger brain it's a
more pedomorphic brain in looking like
the juveniles of the ancestor
but just as our kids are very smart and
can learn amazing things compared to
adults you know all they lack is wisdom
and maturity but they you know in terms
of sheer cognitive ability they got it
and i think that's the same with
domesticated animals compared to their
wild ancestors and probably therefore
with
um homo sapiens say 30 000 years ago
compared to to their ancestors so we
have smaller brains than neanderthals
size
richard isn't everything exactly
what's the connection between fire
cooking and the eating of meat
do you which came first do you think uh
humans
starting to enjoy the eating of meat
or the
the the invention of fire and the use of
fire for cooking i think that fire
increased the using of meat but um
but the fact that chimpanzees uh really
like to hunt and kill meat as do bonobos
certainly puts us in so they they
those two species have a common ancestor
with us going six seven million years
ago and it was from that common ancestor
that you get the australopithecine line
it's very likely therefore astrologians
were eating meat when they could get it
which wouldn't be very often because
they wouldn't be very
good sprinters but nevertheless they
would occasionally be able to get some
meat and i bet they loved it all the
time and basically all primates like
meat if they can get it almost all of
them
but i think fire would have been very
important um for a couple of reasons
uh one is that once you eat fire once
you eat your food cooked then you're
saving yourself time
by saving yourself time
you can free up
the opportunity to go and hunt more
because hunting is a high risk high gain
activity
there's every risk that you will get
nothing on one particular afternoon that
you go off
looking for opportunities to kill
but it's high gain because when you do
get something
you bring down a kudu then
you've got a serious amount of meat
what did
males and females do with the time they
were saving from not having to
chew their food i think that
in the case of males it's very
reasonable to think they spent a greatly
increased amount of time hunting
so chimpanzees
they hunt
maybe two or three times a month and the
average hunt length is 20 minutes
with humans they're
hunting maybe uh 20 times a month
and the average hunt length is six hours
yeah so it's a huge difference yeah
so and that's possible because the time
was available because they were cooking
less chewing more hunting you got it
the other thing is
that the meat
is so much nicer
yeah yeah so when a chimpanzee
kills a monkey and i mean they are so
excited about killing a monkey you know
they are so excited about going into the
hunt and uh when they
make the kill then there's screams
everywhere and uh some try to
seize it and capture it and take it away
from the others and eventually the
strongest one has it and the others sit
around begging and trying to get some
and tear it off and so yeah they all
love it
there are others who he often goes to
the top of a tree
in order to be able to get away from all
of these beggars and scavengers and
while he's there
drops of blood or little scraps will
fall down to the bottom and the junior
members of society you know the females
and young and that sort of thing um they
they are racing through to find a
particular leaf that's got a drop of
blood on it so they can lick it i mean
they love it
but
yes
it takes them a lot of time to chew it i
mean it's the same thing as for cooked
food in general
so um they are getting meats very slowly
into their bodies
and there sometimes comes a time when
they just say i've had enough of this i
need real food and they'll drop the meat
and go off and and eat
fruit again because they can get fruit
into their bodies so much faster than
they can get meat
um
so once they're cooking that problem is
solved and they can eat the meat so this
is much more readily so i think that
meat eating would become important
for two reasons with cooking
so the key uh not to oversimplify but
the key moments in human history
are with the homo erectus
the discovery of fire and the use of
fire for cooking
and then with uh homo sapiens the
the beta males
killing off the alpha males so that the
cooperation can exist and cooperation
leads to
communication and language and ideas the
sharing of ideas that kind of thing
well yes the only thing i would modify
on that is that you have to ask
how is it that the beta males were able
to kill the alpha male
right
and we now know that although
chimpanzees do kill males within their
own group sometimes it's not a process
of killing the alpha male it's taking
advantage of opportunity when some male
gets into a bad position but it's not a
systematic ability to kill the alpha
male
and you can see see why you know because
they don't have language and without
language it's very difficult to know
how confident you can be
of the support of others against a
particular individual within your own
group yes
when you're attacking someone from
another group that problem is solved you
know we all hate the
yes you know
those guys
but
the alpha male has got alliances within
his group
some of those allies might be willing to
to turn against him
some of them might be harboring deep
feelings of resentment
but how does anyone else know that
so in other words i think that you have
to have
some kind of language that is pretty
good
to solve the problems of
gaining confidence
that
five of you say you know or some some
number
um
can trust each other in this final
attack
and you know even nowadays it's it's
difficult uh you know when you mention
stalin
it's like
why was everybody terrified
any dictator that takes control why is
all of us as individuals terrified when
you know there's millions of us
that's right and so like that we lack
the language because our basic
psychology of fear overtakes us like who
can we talk to who can we talk to and
not get killed ourselves exactly that's
right but you're yeah do you have this
intuition that some kind of language was
developing
along with this process
of beta males taking over yes yes i mean
once you have sufficient language to be
able to have the beta males conspiring
to kill the alpha male
then you have selection uh in favor of
cooperation and tolerance as we spoke
about and at that point there will be uh
increased ability to communicate and the
language will get richer and better and
better
so yes absolutely positive feedback loop
once you get the situation started
can you maybe comment on um
the full complexity and richness of the
human mind through this process we've
been casually saying cooking
[Music]
fire
and uh
beta males
leading to cooperation
but how does the the beauty of the human
mind emerge from all of this is there
other further steps we need to
understand or is it as simple as this
language emerging
from
taking over the alpha male and the
cooperation
or am i also over romanticizing how
amazing the human mind is is it just
like one small step in a long journey of
evolution
well if the beauty of the human mind is
the ability
of us all to
be creative
to
explore
i
that's one kind of beauty
another kind of beauty is
the
empathy
that we can show and we think of that as
beautiful because it is a kind of rare
and
uh and special
ability compared to
uh the sort of ordinary selfishness
that
can commonly predominate
um i suppose we have to think of you
know different sources for those those
two types
i suppose you know a general answer is
that
there has been selection in favor of
bigger brains which probably in general
has been associated with increasing
cognitive ability
and as that has happened
i
the complexity of life
has increased
because
people have more and more
complex
highly differentiated strategies in
response to each other's more complex
highly differentiated strategies
and we get to a point where there is
deception and self-deception
there is some
a manipulation of ideas through
stories that we invent and stories that
we pass on
um
you know i guess all i'm
wanting to say is that
there is a world of
the mind
that
evolves in response
to these platforms that are put there
you know the platform of
increasing brain size and therefore
cognitive ability made possible by
uh increased energy supply the platform
of
uh cooperation and
tolerance in a world in which there
remains a lot of conflict
and therefore a need to respond to the
conflict and manipulate your allies
appropriately
you know i don't see beauty as coming uh
either kind of beauty is coming so
totally independently of these things
um you know i don't think there's a
selection
for
staring into the sunset and creating
poetry
yes you know but um i guess sexual
selection
you know males
wanting to impress females in different
ways will lead to
um them wanting to
very poetry
well yes you know show off yeah
in all the different ways so all of
these are natural consequences of uh
just coming up with strategies of how to
cooperate and
how to achieve certain ends so that's
just like a natural
i mean we haven't spoken about sexual
selection but but that is a really
important part of it you know they
trying to out-compete each other in
um
normally without any physical conflict
uh just in order to be able to be chosen
by mates of the opposite sex and and
that that is certainly a major source of
creativity
so
you've studied chimps you also all the
other relatives gorillas what do you
find beautiful and fascinating about
chimps about gorillas about humans maybe
you can paint the the whole picture of
that evolutionary that little local
pocket of the evolutionary tree
how are we related what is the common
ancestor what are the interesting
differences i know i'm asking a million
questions but
um
can you paint a map of
what are chimps gorillas and humans like
how we're related and what you find
fascinating about each
in africa
straddling the equator
there is a strip of rainforest
that
relies on the combination of
high temperatures and rainfall that you
get around the equator
that rainforest goes into about
22 countries
and throughout those countries uh you
have chimpanzees although they've gone
extinct in two of them
i
in
uh
just a fraction of them but i was at
sorry five countries uh you've got
gorillas
where there are mountains
and in one country on the left bank of
the great congo river
you have bonobos
so in the african forest you've got
these three african apes the only
african apes
all of which
are
very similar in
much of their
way of life
they walk on their knuckles
through the forest looking for fruit
trees
and eating
herbs when they can't find fruits
gorillas
represent the oldest chain
so about
10 million years ago maybe as recently
as 8 million years ago
the ancestral gorillas broke off from
the ancestor leading to chimps and
bonobos and humans
so they probably remained very similar
now to what
very similar to what they were then they
were probably
um
the largest apes uh living in mountain
areas and uh spending more time
uh eating just uh
herbs stems
not so vitally dependent on fruit
and
living in um
if there was like the present
uh groups up to about 50 stable groups
with
one alpha male who was in charge
gorillas are
wonderfully
slow
and inquisitive compared to chimps and
bonobos yeah
and i had the
privilege of
um
spending uh a week or two with
gorillas um
at diane fossey's camp when before she
was murdered and i i i went out
with
two women
kelly and bob
to a particular group
and
there was a young female in the group
called simba and simba approached us
and stared at the two women and then she
came towards me
and
she
very deliberately reached out her
knuckles and touched me on the forehead
she was watched in doing this
by a young male who was quite keen on
her
and he was called digit
and about five minutes later
digit
stood in front of us on the path
and kelly was in front of me uh and then
there was bob and then there was me
and he came charging down the path and
he sidestepped around kelly and he
sidestepped around barb
and me
he just knocked with his arm and sent me
flying about five yards into the bushes
and i loved the way that
that was a very deliberate response and
i loved the way that simba had been so
interested in me and and held my eye
chimps and bonobos never hold your eye
but gorillas really look as though
they're trying to figure out what are
you thinking
about that was
a species that has goes back for
something like 10 million years in that
situation
was there a game being played
um
well i mean i i felt that digit was
telling me i don't want you messing with
with simba or was simba
using you
oh i see
well that's a fun idea uh i don't see
why she should be using me but you mean
testing how strongly the affection
preferred to intervene too yeah exactly
oh that's that's
that's comes straight out of a sort of
adolescent to high school playbook all
right well that's that's no no there's
nothing wrong with it brother for that
um yeah
i don't know i never thought of that and
you never know
so
so yeah so okay so this is an ancient
branch of the evolutionary tree uh this
gorilla that led to gorillas gorillas um
so then the next thing that happened on
the evolutionary tree was uh six or
seven million years ago when
uh
you have uh the line
uh between chimps and bonobos on the one
hand and humans on the other splitting
and basically what happened is that
at that point a chimp-like ancestor
uh
leaves the forest
gets isolated in an area outside the
forest and adapts and that becomes the
astrological scenes and meanwhile the
chimpanzees
and bonobo ancestor continues in the
forest
and
later what happens is that one branch of
that crosses the congo river and becomes
the bonobos
that was only about two million years
ago maybe one million years ago
now the chimps that remained in the
forest throughout this time and occupied
all the countries across uh from east
west to east africa now
um again we assume that they're pretty
similar to the ones that live nowadays
whether some variation from from west to
east
and these are animals that live in
social communities of between say 20 and
200. they have a lot of them in one
group but they never come together in a
single unit
these are they share an area a community
territory
and that area is defended by males and
within it females wander and bring up
their young independently
and
the females are very scared about
the possibility that males will be mean
to their infants and in order to
avoid them doing that
they do their best to mate with every
single male in the group multiple times
as if to give a memory in that mail of
yeah yeah i remembered you so i'm not
going to be mean to your baby
so what's wonderful about gyms well you
know as we've spoken about them yeah
they are creative and um uh and so
amazingly human-like
but i love the the sort of you know the
quiet moments and and here's one
um i've got uh
uh two chimps who are uh grooming each
other on a day when they are utterly
exhausted
they've walked um
11 kilometers the day before up and down
hills and
on this particular day all they do is
they get to one tree
and they eat from that tree and other
than that they only walk about 100 yards
and they go back to sleep in the nest in
which they woke up
so they're utterly exhausted um
and they're just eating non-stop because
they're trying to recover uh their
energy
and this is uh hugh and charlie and we
think they were probably brothers so we
never actually got the genetic evidence
to prove it
well um
i never remember now who it is but let's
say that
they both come down from the tree
and um
they're both
carrying branches of the food they're
eating actually seeds from these
branches
they're both engaged
even in the midday sun when they want to
come down and
unshade themselves for a bit on the
ground
um they're still eating but then charlie
finishes his branch
and he starts grooming hugh
and
hugh
continues eating from his branch
charlie eventually gets bored of this
after a few minutes
and he reaches out
and he
lifts the branch from which hugh is
still taking seeds
and
puts it over his head and puts it behind
his back as far as possible away from
you
hugh doesn't do anything
he just finishes his mouthful and then
he turns to charlie and grooms him so
this very polite way of saying will you
groom me please has worked
then
hugh
grooms around charlie's back
and around our to the right side and
then down his arm to what point where he
can reach the branch again
and then he picks up the branch and
continues
nonchalantly right yeah so in other
words you know
a very sort of simple little strategy
yeah but it just shows the the courtesy
with which they can
treat each other
and you know the days i love with gym so
when you see that sort of thing or when
you see
mothers just lying in a sunlit patch in
the forest with babies bouncing on top
of them um just
having a a wonderful peaceful time and
that's you know that's what most of
their lives are like
so chimpanzees are the
species that kind of unites the rest of
the apes because a gorilla is in many
ways a just a big version of a
chimpanzee if you can sort of engineer a
chimpanzee in your mind to be bigger it
basically turns into a gorilla
and then bonobos
on the left bank of the congo river
are a
like a domesticated form of
of chimpanzee but obviously humans
didn't domesticate them so they're
self-domesticated they are less
aggressive and they show all the marks
of domestication that domesticated
animals do in compared to wild animals
in their bones
so they have reduced differences between
males and females in which the males are
more like females they have smaller
brains they have
shorter faces smaller teeth and smaller
bodies
all the things that domesticate animals
show and and bonobos live in this
environment in a strikingly peaceful way
compared to the chimpanzees there's no
indication that they will have these
aggressive kills
and enough data now to show that there's
a statistical difference in the
frequency of which it would happen
and um and bonobos are famously uh
erotic
the females have enlarged sexual
parts
which swell to a particularly
large size compared to the
female chimpanzees
and the females have a lot of
interactions with each other in which
they excitedly rub their clitorises
together and um and appear to have
orgasms and wow these occur in the
context of
um
some kind of social tension and they
sometimes happen before this sounds
happen after the social tension and they
seem to be devices uh these interactions
for um ensuring that everyone's friends
and uh reducing the chances that they're
actually going to get into a fight this
is a kind of uh
conflict resolution through uh
through through sex or some kind of
pleasurable sexual experience well it's
often characterized as make love not war
that's right make love not war
okay
uh
you uh mentioned to me offline that you
you have a deep love for nature
if we look at the world today
how can we ensure that
the beautiful parts of nature
remain a big part of our lives
as human beings
and in the way we think about it in the
way
we also keep it around preserve it
you know we keep it part of our minds
and part of our world
it's a
very difficult question
because
every time there is a conflict between
conservation of a natural habitat and
allowing people to
get a little bit of extra food for their
babies
then
naturally
the tendency is for the humans to win
so we have this steady
erosion
in the face of
tremendous efforts to conserve nature
we have a continuing steady erosion of
habitats and all the species and the
numbers are always in the wrong
direction
occasionally you get sort of wonderful
little examples of something being saved
but
the overall trend is clear
and it's very difficult to see how one
can ever escape that because it's not
human
i know that we are essentially a single
tribe
to
want to save an elephant if it means
killing 20 humans
so i think the only way in which we can
really conserve
is if we
uh put
tremendous effort
into
conserving
the very best
representative areas of nature
often this will be the national parks
that already exist
and what we have to do is to make them
so valuable that actually it is worth it
in terms of human survival to be able to
keep those sorts of places
and
you know that's the attitude that uh
my colleagues and i have taken in uganda
where
we want to
keep the kibani national park alive
which has got the largest population
chimpanzees in uganda and it's got
elephants and wonderful birds and
wonderful butterflies and wonderful
plants and so on
and um and visitors
and lots and lots of visitors it may be
that we're going to have to have
huge increases in the amount of
charges that you pay for eco-tourism and
you need to make sure the ecotourism is
done right
in other places you will
keep nature there because it's useful
for
um
maintaining the climate uh
you're bringing rain uh
maybe uh you can in some places
uh convince people of the sheer sort of
aesthetics of keeping nature
that
even over the long term
presidents whose job it is
to look for the future of the country
will be persuaded that you can do it for
purely aesthetic reasons
but overall
what is required
is for people in the rich countries
to do much more investment than
they have so far
in maintaining both
the natural places in their own
countries
and in the tropics and if you look at
africa you know i mean
the population trends are that
nigeria
may become the most populous country
in the world i think
within a century
future of african habitats you know it's
clear what's going to happen in general
there's going to be a huge conversion
towards agricultural land
uh
i heard ed wilson
speak years ago about the prospect of
the entire globe being turned into a
single human feedlot
it's going to take a lot to avoid that
he is out there
calling for
half the earth
to be devoted to nature
it's incredibly ambitious and incredibly
optimistic
but unless you have
really exciting goals
probably nothing will be achieved
yeah i mean there's something
to me like when i visit new york and i
see central park and somehow constructed
a situation where you preserve this park
in the middle
probably some of the most expensive land
in the world
the fact that that's possible gives me
hope that you can do this kind of
preservation at a global scale
perhaps for just the aesthetic reasons
of just valuing
the beauty and um
just respecting our origins
of having come from the earth
we are so incredibly lucky to have
chimpanzees bonobos and gorillas as our
um close relatives still living on the
earth you know we're unlucky that we
don't have astrology and other species
of homo but we're still lucky to have
those because they are incredibly
closely related to us compared to what
most animals have you know there are
many animals that don't have any close
relatives to them on the earth but not
only are they they're relatively close
but they teach us so much about
ourselves you know they the similarities
between them and ourselves raise
questions that we can then test
about
the extent to which our own behavioral
propensities are derived from the same
evolutionary stock as in those great
apes
well how much is that worth you know i
mean we could spend billions going to
the mars to
find
evidence of bacteria there and that's
fascinating too
but we should be spending billions on
this earth in order to
make sure
that we have
i don't know how to say it you know
substantial representative populations
are these close relatives
yeah that we can meet there's something
um like space tourism when you go out
into space and you look back down on
earth
that's to a lot of people including
myself is worth a lot
but why is that worth a lot is because
you uh
it's humbling
and
beautiful
in the same way that meeting our close
evolutionary relatives is humble and and
beautiful
just to know that this
this is what we come from this is who we
are
not just for the understanding or the
science of it but just like something
about just the beauty of witnessing this
um and it's again it's both humbling and
empowering
that this place is fragile and we're
damn lucky to be here
yes unfortunately the problems are
incredibly difficult
to solve and there is no one solver you
know it has to happen from a network of
potentially cooperating people
but but i mean you're so right about it
being daunting to to think about what it
looks like from space and i love the
view that herman muller expressed
of uh
being able to go out from space and he
said the whole of life
uh would look like a kind of rust on the
planet
yeah so the aliens were to visit i'm not
sure they would notice the life they
would probably notice the
trees or
ocean
it's it's a kind of rust but let me ask
the big ridiculous philosophical
question
of what is the meaning of this rust
what do you think is the meaning of life
on earth
what is the meaning of our human
intelligent life
well i think it's very clear that um
we have an evolutionary story uh that
uh
is only getting
challenged around the edges you know we
we have a very clear understanding of
the evolution of life
and
the meaning is you know we are here
as a consequence of
materialistic processes
that
began uh in our sense uh you know with
the
establishment of the earth the four and
a half billion years ago whatever it was
and then water and
oxygen and and so on um
and you know we are the astonishing
uh
uh consequence
of um
the evolution of of cells and and
multicellular organisms
uh
the word random is the wrong word to use
unless you understand what it means
you know
it didn't happen
by chance but a lot of random events had
to happen to make this possible
and those random events of course
are the production of uh appropriate
mutations
but the um you know the meaning of life
is
there is no meaning
it's the you know the really big mystery
of life is why is there a universe
and that same y propagates itself
through the whole of it
through the whole process of it for the
emergence of planets the virgins first
of all galaxies of
star systems of planets of
the proteins required to construct the
single cell organisms and the single
cell organism becoming complex organisms
and uh some of the clever fish
crawling out onto the land and and the
whole of it and then there's fire some
some clever
uh clever guy or lady invented fire and
then now here we are
uh it just does seem
speaking as a human kind of special they
were able to reflect on the whole thing
where the whole wonderful story is so
much more interesting than the stories
produced by religion
yeah it is it is beautiful but it just
seems special that us humans are able to
write religions and
construct stories yeah and and also do
science
that seems uh
that seems kind of amazing it seems like
the universe
is such
that it it um it creates
beings like us that are able to
investigate
it
and that and that that's why there's
this longing for why
it's just uh
such a beautiful little pocket of
complexity created by the universe it
seems like um
it seems like there should be a y but
maybe there's just an infinite number of
universes and this is the one
that uh
led to this particular set of humans
even without an infinite number of
universes i bet there's an infinite
number of intelligent beings throughout
this universe yeah now that we know how
many planets are
have the right sort of conditions
you know which is what i can't remember
a lot you know it's some significant
percentage of all planets
um then
then there are apparently billions of
planets
and
there's every i mean things happen so
quickly on earth you know once you've
got water then uh you've got life and um
it did not take long for for life to
evolve in in the big scheme of things
and if you think you look out there
say there's a nearly infinite number of
intelligent civilizations
one dimension you could look at is the
proclivity to violence they have it's
interesting to think
what level of violence is useful
for
extending the life of a civilization so
we have a particular set of violence in
our history
maybe being too peaceful is a problem in
the early days
uh maybe being too violent quite
obviously is as a problem so you look at
viruses what kind of viruses on earth
propagate and succeed if you're too
deadly that's a big problem
uh if you're not deadly enough that's
also a problem
so
so that is a fascinating exploration of
i don't see any evidence i don't see
where you're coming from when you say
that being too peaceful is a problem
well because
so i'll say it this way
death
is a way
to get rid of suboptimal solutions
so violence but there's lots of ways to
die without violence right
to me death in itself is violence
and
you you can i mean a lot of people that
talk about for example longevity and and
disease and all that kind of stuff they
see death is uh
this is the way they they talk about it
and it's interesting to philosophically
think of it that way
death is
it's like mass murder that's happening
it's like people that try to from a
biological perspective help extend life
they see that you're
you're helping
the most
the biggest atrocity in the history of
human civilization from their
perspective
is
not
allocating all our resources to solving
death
right because death is a kind of
violence it is the kind of murder that
we're allowing
to be committed on us by nature and so
so the flip side of that is death makes
way for new life
for new ideas
and so that's but but that's got nothing
to do with with peace versus war
you know i mean you you have animals
that are very very peaceful but but they
evolved just in the same way as as other
animals do they they just don't do it
with with death caused by violence and
violent death is premature death surely
i mean you know i don't mind about
people dying um you know what what i
mind about is people dying uh in the
in in their youth
prematurely but some people would say
all death is premature it certainly
feels that way it's uh
died too soon anyone who's ever died
died too soon yeah well i mean if we can
become like sequoias you know and and
live for
hundreds of years and thousands of years
that would be great
do you ponder your own mortality
are you afraid of death
i don't think i'm afraid of it um you
know i'm reconciled to the fact it's
going to happen
um
i i just feel frustrated because i enjoy
life you know and i don't want to
to leave the party
yeah
it's kind of a fun party
i don't want to leave the party either
so however we got here we made one heck
of an awesome party and you're right uh
having a party with a little bit less
violence in it is an even more fun party
richard i'm deeply honored that you
spent time with me today your work is
amazing it's
includes
some of the deepest thinking about
our human history and the nature of
human civilization so again thank you so
much for talking today it's an honor oh
thanks for your great questions it's a
really fun conversation
thanks for listening to this
conversation with richard wrangham to
support this podcast please check out
our sponsors in the description
and now let me leave you some words from
jane goodall
the greatest danger to our future
is apathy
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time